new questions this morning over law
enforcement response to the protests
protests which themselves were against
police brutality demonstrations were
almost exclusively peaceful yesterday at
events held all across the country
including in Brooklyn New York but when
that March in Brooklyn went past an 8
p.m. curfew officers charged the crowd
using batons and chasing people down who
were trying to avoid arrest our national
correspondent Jericka Duncan is outside
Brooklyn's Barclays Center which has
been a rallying point for these
demonstrations and where that protest
started Jericho good morning good
morning to you this was the seventh
straight day that we've had so far a
mostly peaceful protest here in New York
City and thousands more are expected to
gather in a nearby park later today and
cross the Brooklyn Bridge in honor of
Floyd's death other three officers are
being charged hundreds of protestors in
New York City erupted in cheers after
hearing the three other former officers
involved in George Floyd's death will
now face charges what did you make of
that I think it's the right decision
obviously but I still don't think it's
enough it's a bigger problem than just
George Floyd this isn't the first and it
won't be the last the issue will be
whether they can take it through the
court system and have convictions New
York protesters continued peaceful
demonstrations Wednesday but after an A
p.m. curfew went into effect NYPD
officers cracked down on demonstrators
and Brooklyn
witnesses say there were no calls for
the crowd to disperse and in a chaotic
scene police used their batons to
physically move a large crowd of
protesters some fell to the ground and
others were restrained the protesters
were actually move in as they requested
and they were still pushing them and
hitting them I saw cops actually diving
that protester one person got hurt we're
just walking police also seen chasing
some of the protesters as they left the
area it was in sharp contrast to Seattle
where the mayor cancelled the city's
nightly curfew because of the size and
peaceful nature of the crowd and in
Detroit the demonstrations were also
allowed to run long Police Chief James
Craig they're peaceful as everybody can
see there's no problems that once a
voice is heard and we support down today
governor in Virginia Ralph Northam is
expected to announce the removal of the
statue of Robert Ely the Confederate
General a number of protesters have been
putting signs on their spray-painting
signs to end white supremacy now
historians will say that Robert Ely was
not for slavery but he obviously
supported the Confederacy and Anthony
weeks before the Civil War it was the
vice president of the Confederacy
Alexander Stephens that gave a speech
and ended he said with us all of the
white race however high or low rich or
poor are equal in the eyes of the law
not so for the negro
Jericka as we know there are many
confederate general statues down the
main promenade there in Richmond so and
they've been a point of dispute for
quite a while
Thank You jerrika